[Musique]
donc nous sommes tellement ravis que cela signifie
tout pour moi que nous soyons ici
ensemble et pour ma charmante épouse Mina
peut-être que tu peux partir surfer en
Californie
Tom je veux que tu rencontres Alice Manning Alice
ravie de te rencontrer
tu la connais  elle vient de débarquer du
bateau d'Australie j'ai à peu près vécu
dans un marais tasmanien depuis l'âge de 24 ans
Jenny je suis désolée Jenny allez c'est toi
tu es en vie ça fait 15 ans
je ne suis pas Jenny allez tu as complètement
disparu depuis  15 ans et puis tu te
pointes raconter cette histoire de fou je viens juste
de me tirer ici pour me traiter de menteur je
m'entends à voix haute tout ça
semble
fou  ce qui t'est arrivé je
ne veux pas voir quelque chose c'est quoi
c'est fou
la piste
montre moi qui tu es maintenant
toi